vous avez fait léon morin prêtre vous
avez fait l'armée des ombres l'intel sur
la résistance l'autre telle étude un
caractère de prêtres mais quand on
regarde tous vos films on s'aperçoit
qu'il ya quand même une majorité de
films dix policiers pourquoi disons que
j'aime bien faire des films que
j'aimerais voir et par exemple alain
delon et moi nous avons un projet c'est
de tourner pour le cinéma et pour la
première fois un vrai arsène lupin qui
n'a jamais été fait et ça c'est tout
simplement parce que depuis 41 ans
j'ai envie de voir un film sur un samuel
j'en ai jamais et alain alors vous aussi
dans votre carrière
il y à une prédominance de rôles de
mauvais garçon n'importe quel personnage
dans le cercle rouge par exemple bon
sens si vous me demandez quel est votre
personnage
je vous répondrai c'est un loup un loup
solitaire pourquoi alain affectionner
vous justement les personnages de
solitaire vous êtes quelqu'un à qui tout
a réussi qui est entouré vous trouvez
cette possibilité de solitude en bout
oui je pense que toute façon chacun et
solitaire un niveau différent et les
proportions différentes moi je ne suis
sûrement je le suis même certainement
donc je le trouve en moins vous semblez
choisir des personnages qui ne sont pas
a priori des personnages sympathiques
l'import si un personnage sympathique ou
antipathique je crois que ce qui est
plus important c'est de savoir si on se
sent coller un personnage si on a envie
de l'interpréter et mon dieu si on a
envie de jouer et suivant le metteur en
scène qui vous dirigera je veux dire
jean pierre venayre de miles le sait il
me dit ah là on va faire ça du jean
pierre fons fait ce que vous voulez
ça ne se passe pas de la même façon avec
d'autres on parle beaucoup en ce moment
deux films qui mettent la police en
mauvaise posture dans votre film on voit
d'ailleurs je crois pour la première
fois à l'écran un inspecteur igf et qui
dit cette phrase qui m'a beaucoup frappé
personne n'est innocent à quoi un
policier ne répondent même pas les
policiers dit tous sont coupables
il y a en ce moment et s'il va y avoir
pléthore de films sur la police tendant
terre a jugé la police
ça n'a pas été mon propos duty ce
scénario est à ce qui a été écrit quand
il ya deux ans pile deux ans déjà et il
n'était pas question à cette époque là
te trouvais que l'histoire sur les
policiers étaient des histoires la mode
je me défends bien de vouloir jamais
traité d'une histoire de policiers en
présentant ou un schizophrène ou un
paranoïaque mon policier allemand est un
homme extrêmement normande c'est un
brave homme alors quand les armes sont
ils coupables ils peuvent être coupables
un temps et puis innocent ensuite en
tout cas mes héros ne sont pas coupables
et vous alain qu'est-ce que qu'est ce
qui fait qu'un homme est coupable
je crois que la phrase i policier est
une phrase qui n'a pas grand sens c'est
une phrase de deux vieux policier pour
moi je ne fais pas donné discussions ni
de polémique avec la police
si j'ai un bon rôle de policier un jour
je serai ravie d'interpréter se trouve
que c'est plus souvent des gangsters
qu'on présente mais j'attends qu'on de
policiers et qu'est ce qu'elle est le
plus grand péché à la tempête que table
je suis obligé de faire un rapport
directement avec l'ennemi en france
alors là c'est assez gênant très
objectivement un fait certain que sur un
certain temps la trahison pour moi est
une faute capitale